today on the Matt Walsh show a Harvard
professor has made the case for banning
homeschooling and her argument of course
is insane on many levels we'll get into
all of that I'll dissect her argument
today also five headlines including the
media freaking out because people in
Florida are committing the crime of
going to the beach but isn't it a lot
healthier and safer to be outside in the
Sun in the fresh air then inside
breathing recirculated air along with
the other people in your house and in
our daily cancellation we canceled a CNN
anchor who cried for a reason that is
not on the approved reasons for a man to
cry list and so we'll talk about that it
will go over that list again because
it's very important that that we all
understand that so all of that coming up
but first I want to tell you about our
friends and sponsors over at honey now
now obviously is a great time to shop
online it's you know depending on what
you want to buy it might be your only
option anyway and so if you're going to
be shopping online during this time or
at any other time you need to have honey
honey is the free shopping online
shopping tool that saves you money
online honey automatically finds the
best promo codes and applies them to
your cart which makes online shopping
finally feel as easy as it's supposed to
be and as cheap as it's supposed to be
you know imagine you're shopping at one
of your favorite sites whether it's
Target or Best Buy or Macy's or whatever
when you check out this little box drops
down and all you have to do is click
apply coupons wait a few seconds for it
to scan for every promo code on the
internet and then you just watch those
prices drop and that's you that's
basically money that's going right back
into your pocket you know I've been
using using honey now for a couple of
months and I can't even tell you how
much money I've saved because I don't I
don't keep track of it which would also
require me to keep track of all the
things that I buy which I don't really
want to do but I've saved a lot of money
on hunting it and it really is as easy
as just clicking a button and then you
save the money honey is found it's over
18 million members over two billion
dollars in savings users love honey
that's why it has over a hundred
thousand five star reviews on the google
chrome store not using honey is
literally passing up free money why
would anyone pass up free money doesn't
make any sense it's free to use you
stall just a few seconds plus it's
backed by PayPal so you know it's good
get honey for free at joint honey calm
slash Walsh that join honey dot-com
slash Walsh alright with schools across
the country shut down millions of
parents of course have discovered the
considerable joys and also considerable
challenges of homeschooling and I think
this has made our betters in the media
and academia extremely nervous and for
good reason really because what if a
sizable portion of these parents decide
that they quite prefer teaching their
own kids what if they never send their
offspring back into the government's
education factories well then they our
betters I mean may lose their hold on an
entire generation of children and that
would be a great tragedy for them anyway
for our kids that would be great but for
our betters it would be would be pretty
bad and that's why we're seeing now this
sort of full-court press from academia
and the media against home schooling
which home schoolers know that for
decades we've been sustaining these
attacks on the fact that we educate our
children but it's just been ramped up in
recent weeks so there was a recent
article in The Washington Post which was
pretty forthright about these fears the
editorial claimed quote home schooling
during the quarter virus will set back a
generation of children and then Harvard
Law School is holding a summit to
discuss these problems the summit will
focus especially on quote educational
deprivation and child maltreatment that
too often occurs under the guise of
homeschooling in a legal environment of
minimal or no oversight and the
conversation will be led by experts of
course you always gotta have those
experts in there who will offer
suggestions on quote legal reform for
home schooling now you hear legal reform
you think what does that mean well to
give you an idea of what legal reform
might mean at least to the folks over at
Harvard we can look at an article that
was just published in Harvard magazine
titled the risks of home schooling and
it's accompanied accompanied by this
unintentionally ironic picture which
I'll show you here take a look at this
picture
so you see there's a homeschooled child
locked in a prison made of books which
there's a lot to be said about that
image the books are a prison but so the
the homeschool child is locked in in
prison
looking out despairingly at all of these
public school children who are outside
frolicking you know in the great
outdoors that that's how they want us to
see the dichotomy between public school
and home school of course in reality
it's exactly the opposite the public
school child is chained to a desk in a
government building for eight hours a
day it's the home school child who can
go outside whenever they please
you know we homeschool and my especially
when it's a nice out my my wife will
take the kids outside dogs but we can
pumps go outside you can homeschool in
you could homeschool anywhere so it's
it's public school where you know you
might get you get with 35 minutes of rec
time like you're in prison where the
kids can go outside in the very in a
very controlled environment
don't play dodgeball you know don't play
probably you don't want to play any
aggressive games kickball probably no
good but but they can go outside and
play approved recreation for for 35
minutes that that's the public school
environment not the home school
environment now while the picture is a
hilariously poor representation of
homeschooling it is a spot-on
representation of the article which time
and time again confuses the problems of
public school with the problem of
home-school with the problems in home
school the piece extensively quotes
Elizabeth Barthel a I'll just pronounce
her name that way who we are told is the
Public Interest professor of law and
faculty director of the law school child
advocacy program at Harvard and Barthel
a advocates an outright ban on the
dangerous practice of parents teaching
their own kids and all the reasons she
gives are both illogical and morally
absurd so let's go through and take a
look at there's basically three points
to her argument and we'll go through
each each of those three points one she
worries that the unregulated regime of
home
schooling as she puts it unregulated
regime might allow parents who quote
don't read or rights to handle or rather
I suppose miss handle their children's
education and as evidence of this
problem she points to a memoir written
by a woman who was homeschooled by
survivalists in Idaho and I guess she
thinks that that's a fairly
representative of the way most people
are home-schooled now if if if she got
any evidence any actual evidence that
any significant or even in significant
percentage of homeschool parents are
illiterates then she should provide it
but giving us an anecdote about
survivalists in Idaho is is not going to
cut it because I would dare say that a
sizable majority of homeschool parents
are not Idahoan survivalists right
nothing against Idaho and survivalist by
the way besides 2p2 can play at the
anecdote game right as I was public
school for 12 years 13 years including
kindergarten and I could give you plenty
of anecdotes sorry if we want to play
the anecdote game I could we could do
this all day
so I could for example tell you about
the geography teacher I had in high
school who didn't know that Georgia was
the name of a state and a country or I
could tell you about the Spanish teacher
I had in seventh grade who was rather
hampered in her Spanish teaching duties
by the fact that she apparently could
not speak Spanish and so instead we
watched the movie Selena with Jennifer
Lopez about five times all the way
through during school so for every story
about dumb and neglectful homeschool
parents which I admit that there are
that they exist but for every one story
of those you could you could you could
present I could dig up ten about dumb
and neglectful public school teachers so
this this isn't gonna work
now if we're going beyond mere anecdotes
to compare the relative quality of home
school and public school and we start
looking at data and statistics home
school still fares pretty well home
schoolers tend to perform better than
the national average on both the AC t--
and the SAT now granted standardized
tests are in my opinion not a good way
to measure the
things but that in itself is another
argument against public school as the
entire public school system is
structured around these tests but the
point is that homeschooled kids can beat
the public school kids at their own game
and succeed and do better on them on the
standardized tests than they do and this
is a fact that I'm convinced makes the
Elizabeth Barthel A's of the world hate
home school even more now putting
standardized tests to the side all we
need to do is take a look around society
a society which is largely the product
of the public school system to see how
effective that system has been because
but by their fruits you shall know them
right according to a certain hugely
influential book that public that at
least kids in home school are still
allowed to study whereas a pub in public
school you're not allowed to but surveys
and studies show that most American
adults are downright ignorant subjects
like civics geography math now most
Americans may know how to read and and
most homeschool parents do as well and
despite what what we're told in this
article but they've largely given up on
the practice which which to me is an
even even more disturbing indicator it's
not just that many Americans are poorly
educated it's that they've given up on
education and I think in large part
because they've been so poorly educated
they have no interest in learning
anymore so they leave public school then
they maybe they go to college and they
leave college and they give up a learnin
they don't read anymore they don't learn
anything that's what you see when you
look around now it would be irrational
to lay the blame for all of this
entirely at the feet of public school
I'm not saying that we do that but it
also would be irrational to survey this
landscape of ignorance and stupidity
that is modern American culture and
conclude that the education system is
doing a bang-up job it obviously isn't
it's doing a very poor job and that's a
big part of the reason why parents are
pulling their kids out of it now we'll
go to the second argument which is even
worse than the first but before we do I
want to tell you about our sponsors at
LegalZoom you know it's really important
having a state plan and and you know
especially these days where people are
thinking about this and for good reason
health and safety is on the top of
everybody's
right now no matter what happens you
want to make sure that your loved ones
are protected and that's why LegalZoom
continues to provide a reliable way for
everyone to set up the right estate plan
without leaving your home either so you
can do this all at home it starts with
finding the answers to your questions
like do you need a last will and
testament or living trust what about an
advanced health care directive what's
power of attorney like really basic
questions right the kind of questions
that I have I'm sure you have thankfully
you don't have to figure out that stuff
out on your own you also don't have to
spend hours googling and getting
different answers and you don't know
what to trust legal tsums online
resources make it easy to get started
and if you need to speak to an attorney
their independent attorney network is
there to guide you and advise you Legal
Zoom isn't a law firm so you won't have
to worry about expensive billable hours
adding up take an important step for
your family today go to legalzoom.com to
get started on a last will living trust
and more and make sure you enter code
Walsh when you go there as well a check
out for special savings that's
legalzoom.com code Walsh Legal Zoom
where life meets legal okay so the
second argument she gives she says that
homeschools families are driven by
conservative Christian beliefs god
forbid and that some of these parents
quote are extreme religious ideologues
who questioned science and promote
female subservience and white supremacy
now her fears in this case are partially
justified of course because it is indeed
true that many homeschool parents have
committed the crime of being Christian
but then all educators in all
educational environments have underlying
beliefs and inevitably they will bring
those underlying beliefs into the
classroom with them whether that's in
home school or public school it's going
it's going to happen it does happen as
for the notion that homeschool parents
promote female subservience and white
supremacy I mean this is of course
nothing short of just ridiculous
fear-mongering that has no evidentiary
basis whatsoever and she doesn't bother
to try to prove that I think her
research and homeschooling apparently
has consisted of reading like Jezebel
calm and the daily coasts and and that's
it now as far as homeschool parents
questioning science and rejecting
science and this is you hear this a lot
from the anti homeschool crowd that
they're worried that homeschool kids
will not get a good science education
because these are all science deniers
right that homeschool their kids I have
to ask though we need some qualification
here because when she says questioning
science does she mean actual science or
the kind of quote science they teach in
public school these days the kind that
says that girls have penises and boys
can get pregnant because if that's the
kind of science she's talking about then
yes as a homeschool parent I fully admit
I questioned that science in fact that
science is again one of the reasons why
my kids are not stepping foot in a
public school classroom three finally
she says that some who homeschool
parents might abuse their children and
she explains that most public school
teachers are mandated reporters to the
government and so they can alert
authorities if there's signs of abuse in
the home and she says if a child doesn't
go to school then there's an she's being
abused there's not gonna be anybody
there there might not be anyone there to
save him from the abuse now the problem
with this argument is that it completely
fails to account for the abuse that
happens in public school there was a
study commissioned a few years ago
several years ago by the Department of
Education this is a Department of
Education Commission study that found
that one in ten public school kids are
victims of sexual misconduct by
educators that's ten percent ten percent
of kids are victims of some form of
sexual harassment abuse or misconduct by
educators now there's how many kids go
to public school I think it's like 50
million or something like that so 10% of
that you do the math and that's to say
nothing of the many thousands of
children who have been sexually abused
at school by other students now when you
compare this to the rate of abuse at
home and even when you compare just
sexual abuse in in school to all forms
of abuse at home even when you do that
comparison
it seems still apparent that a child who
is home-schooled is is is you know will
not be rescued from his situation by a
vigilant teacher it seemed it seems
pretty apparent that a child is more
likely to be abused
school then at home that's what the
numbers tell us when you look at the
numbers percentage of kids that are
abused at home versus percentage of kids
that are abused in school and when you
look at those numbers it's more likely
to happen at school so the idea of the
school being there as this Savior to
save kids from abuse that does happen
sometimes but it's more likely so yes
you may have kids who are abused at home
and then are saved from it because a
teacher at school notices and is
vigilant that does happen but it's much
more common that a kid who is not abused
at home goes to school and is abuse
there now on top of all this public
school also offers bullying suicide drug
abuse alcoholism social ostracization
peer pressure you know when you consider
the myriad dangers of public school and
the harmful effect it's so often has and
the generally abysmal job it has done of
educating our children you start to
think that if we're banning any form of
school maybe it should be public school
that we ban now I'm not sure that I
would go that far but I could make a
much more persuasive argument in that
direction than the one that Harvard
magazine has offered or that any anti
homeschool person offers against
homeschooling but as I said at the top
even though their arguments are absurd
and are easily debunked they have
there's a good reason for these people
to be nervous about homeschooling or for
them to oppose it because when it comes
down to it they want to have control
over your children they don't trust you
it's not that I don't trust you because
they think that you're physically
abusing your kids no they don't trust
you to instill the right values in your
kid this is all about values and ideas
and they don't they don't trust you with
that and so they want you to send your
kid into the government building for
eight hours a day five days a week nine
months a year for the first thirteen
years of their of their or at least four
thirteen for thirteen years or more of
their formative years they want you to
do that so that they can take over that
part of it and make sure that your kids
become the right sort of person in their
minds
now let's move on to headlines number
one Florida opened their beaches back up
and the media has not stopped having a
panic attack over it
just to give you one example among many
there's this headline in The Daily Beast
it says very very scary
officials dumbfounded as Florida beaches
reopen three days after death spike and
the article goes on to quotes local
officials who are very scared and
scandalized by all the people allegedly
packing the beaches now a guy who works
on the Biden campaign posted a viral
tweet showing the carnage take a look at
this picture here and with the caption
says Jacksonville Beach reopen 26
minutes ago this is a live picture oh my
gosh terrible so this is terrifying look
at all those look at all those families
spaced out on the beach in the open air
in the Sun wait so what exactly is the
problem here because when I look at that
picture I see clumps of people who we
can assume our families they went to the
beach together most people don't go to
the beach by themselves so would I see
our little clumps of people families and
then I see a lot of space in between the
clumps and so I don't understand what
the problem is and then the hill posted
a montage of a video footage of the
beaches and this is all again supposed
to be terrifying when you see all these
allegedly stupid people wreckless who've
gone to the beach so let's look at this
montage and again for the most part
people are spaced out now you do see
groups closer together but those are in
the shots where people are walking by
each other so we're not we're not
looking at a bunch of a whole crowds of
people setting up shop you know camping
out right next to each other they're
just walking by each other on the way to
somewhere else now let me ask you what
is the chance that you transmit or catch
the virus while whack while walking past
someone for two seconds outside in the
Sun in the heat in the open air what's
the chance I know I'm not saying it's
impossible but what's the chance of it
happening I don't know the answer to
that and neither does anyone freaking
out about this but all of the available
research tells us that the virus does
poorly outside and especially in the Sun
and it is not it is not very efficiently
transmitted when you're out in the air
where there's air circulation so the
chance is very low I think we can at
least say that very very low and I would
argue that the negligible risk is
counterbalanced by the psychological and
physical benefits of getting exercise
and getting Sun now by the way drive
throughs are still open everywhere in
the country as far as I know even places
like Dunkin Donuts are open so you can
drive through now Dunkin Donuts
apparently is essential because you
might really need that doughnut which
okay I get sometimes donuts are
essential but you can you can go to the
drive-thru at Dunkin Donuts for example
and come within six feet of another
person to get a doughnut now they do
have to you might be in the
drive-through but you are I mean most
people their wingspan isn't more than
six feet so you gotta get closer than
six feet so they can pass the doughnut
suit unless you're unless you're you
know 50 feet away and they're just then
they're throwing you the doughnuts maybe
we'll get to the point where that's how
it's done but right now you're getting
within six feet so somebody can hand you
a doughnut which they touched with their
hands so let's think about this for a
second
which what which of those is more
dangerous to eat a doughnut that a
stranger hands to you or to walk by a
stranger on the beach now both I think
are very safe and nothing to worry about
but which is more likely to be an
occasion of viral transmission
seems pretty obvious to me that it's the
one where you're putting something in
your mouth that a stranger has touched
yet everybody is shaming the people on
the beach not the people in line for a
glazed doughnut that's me doesn't make
any sense and there's a lot of shaming
happening here's video someone took of
people at a park this is not in in
Florida but and this is at a park but
again shaming them for being outside so
you look at this once again what's the
problem people are well
there outdoors there in the Sun
meanwhile you're filming while you're
driving just so you could be a snitch
which is a greater danger to public
health someone who's more than six feet
away from you outside or someone who's
filming while driving number two there
were protests all across the country
this weekend thousands of people taken
to the street to demand an end to the
lockdowns of course many proponents of
the lockdowns have been less than
charitable to the protesters shall we
say accusing them of being selfish
stupid conspiracy theorists so on and so
on but if you're wondering why these
people are protesting let me give you a
little hint here's a shot of a food bank
line in Texas and this is happening all
over the country we've seen images like
this in Maryland Pennsylvania Florida
California all over the country we've
seen this so if people are protesting
you know if you're confused about it
you're wondering why would people
protest well maybe it's because they
can't eat you thought about that maybe
it's because they would like to be able
to eat and the government has taken that
ability from them now for another hint
at why might people might protest we
could look at this image from a CNN
article it's a woman who was protesting
in Maryland and she's got a very crudely
made sign and she's saying she wants to
save her business you know she needs her
business to live that's her livelihood
which makes sense doesn't it you may not
agree with the protesters you may
support the lockdown still but if you
sneer in contempt at them as so many
people have been doing then you're just
a bad person because any decent person
agree or not can at least understand why
desperate people who've had everything
taken from them and cannot even afford
to eat or to feed their children would
want this to end you should at least be
able to understand that and sympathize
with it it is not selfish or dumb for a
person to fight to protect what they
work their entire lives for it it is not
selfish or dumb for them to fight so
they can feed
kids and care for their families you
know I got into a back-and-forth with
somebody uh yesterday online and they
were telling me that you know it is it
is selfish and dumb because you know you
besides it'sit's you don't really need
your job the government will take care
of you you see if the government's their
government can give you money well the
problem there is number one that
solution isn't working and we'll talk
more about this in a minute but a lot of
people who need the money aren't getting
it a lot of people who are getting the
money need a lot more than what they're
getting the government cannot step in
and become the sugar daddy for tens of
millions of Americans all at once you
just can't do that the money has to come
from somewhere and it doesn't work and
besides that this this person who I was
talking to I was a was a man a man
allegedly and I think a man especially
should understand you know this as a at
least for me as a man I want to be able
to provide for my family not have the
government do it I want to provide for
my family and if you took that away from
even if you took that away from me
even if the government was able to step
in and compensate which it wouldn't be
able to do but even if it did that would
still be a great tragedy for me because
I want to provide for them and you are
taking that from me that is something
real and important that you are taking
from me and from my family that's
something that every man should be able
to understand and if you're a man and
you act like you don't understand that
then I have to question your basic
manhood honestly now I'm not saying
there is exactly my point I'm not saying
that if you if you're a man and you're
not able to provide for your family
right now and the government has to step
in not saying you're less of a man my
point is it's a terrible thing that's
that's happened to you I'm sympathizing
with you and if I was in your boat well
look if I was if I lost my income I
would take whatever help I could get for
the sake of my family and that would in
that sense in that case be the manly
thing to do to humble yourself but it's
it's it's it's not ideal it's not good
it's
to tragedy and I just can't help but
take note of the fact that seemingly the
vast majority of people criticizing the
lockdown protesters certainly the
loudest and most visible critics in
media still have incomes they have an
income but they're calling you selfish
for wanting your income back yeah three
and here are bulldozers in California
filling a skate park in with sand the
Venice skate park to stop people from
skateboarding there so there you go
once again you know because of course we
don't want people outside you know yeah
if your skateboard past somebody I'm
sure there's a real outside I'm sure
there's real great trance a chance of
the virus being transmitted right and
you know it's better to rather than
having the kids outside and the Sun and
the open air rather than that let's have
them inside with their older relatives
having prolonged contact with our old
around that's that's a much better plan
right for here's an MSNBC report about
police departments across the country
using Chinese made drones to spy on
citizens for the sake of enforcing
social distancing and once you
especially pay attention to when when
they're listing the areas where you
might be spied on there's one area in
particular that I think should cause
your ears to perk up watch this mayor's
need to be creative we have to figure
out a way to get to people that police
cars can't get to Elizabeth City police
shot this video force to show us how
drones work the drones make it easier
for police to see into certain areas
where access by patrol cars is more
difficult that includes tight spaces
between buildings behind schools and in
backyards
failure to comply could lead to a
summons or $1,000 fine you think that
drones watching over people is a good
idea a bad idea I think at any at this
point it's worth the try it's just an
invasion of your privacy
the mayor's heard it all my answer to
those people are
if these drones save one life it is
clearly worth the activity and the
information that the drones are sending
the drones donated by DJI a Chinese
company have gone to 43 agencies in 22
states all to help enforce social
distancing rules
authorities say the drones aren't taking
pictures or collecting evidence it's a
high-tech warning against a deadly virus
back yards that you heard that right
they said they're spying on you in your
backyard with a drone that was helpfully
donated from China I'm sure out of the
goodness of their heart China out of the
goodness of his heart has donated spy
drones that police departments can use
to spy on Americans when they're in
their prime sitting on their own
property and then the mayor there gives
us the old if it saves one life bits I
mean they're still giving us this if it
saves one life you know if it saves one
life I because I'm I'm the humanitarian
this is this is really I'm so concerned
about saving lives that's all this is
about that's it well guess what no no it
is not worth it if you save one life
it's not worth you spying on me in my
own yard if it saves a life I'll tell
you this I don't care if it saves 10,000
lives which it won't
by the way okay the drones not gonna
save any lives it's gonna save zero
lives but even if it save 10,000 lives
it's not worth the price of having our
privacy completely destroyed and being
spied on the in the government by the
government when we sit in our own yards
I mean
maybe you could save lives by performing
random house checks maybe going
door-to-door barging into people's homes
checking to make sure they're washing
their hands correctly and so on in fact
you know what actually maybe install
install cameras in people's bathrooms in
kitchens to just to you know make and
have hand-washing experts in the
government watching and if somebody
doesn't wash their hands properly you
know they can come on over the the
intercom and they can give give
instructions citizen you did not wash
your hands correctly maybe something
like that
that could save lives good but you know
I guess I'm so cruel and heartless I
would say I don't care if that would
save a million lives I would say
absolutely not the the complete
forfeiture of our privacy and freedom is
not worth it
period he's not worth it I would rather
die than have that I would rather be
dead that used to be the American
attitude that in fact is the attitude
that our country was literally founded
on and now you have people embracing
this kind of stuff because they're
scared it's pathetic but of course you
know we're really playing the
government's game in a way when we argue
about whether this is worth it to save
lives because it's not saving lives
first of all and that's not why they're
doing it anyway that's not the point
so I feel the need to engage with this
argument of it's worth it would save
what save one life but but maybe the
best thing is to not engage with it
because this is just the excuse they're
giving do you really think the mayor
whatever mayor that was there don't
remember sending spy drones to your
house you really think he's a
humanitarian who care who gives a damn
about saving lives no it's just power
it's it's enormous power and he sank
himself oh my gosh you mean I you know I
have these fancy drones now that I can
go spy on people awesome that's all the
thought going into it from people like
that that goober there that you saw it's
just whoa cool I could Spile people
sweet that is the entites it that's the
entire thought process
number five Shake Shack has announced
that it's returning a 10 million dollar
government loan that was part of the
small business relief package for the
coronavirus and they're returning it
saying they don't need it
and good for Shake Shack so they should
be applauded for that a little little
positivity there but of course this race
is a question of why Shake Shack which
is definitely not a small business ever
got a small business loan as part of the
coronavirus relief effort and they
aren't the only ones by longshot
many large restaurant chains and other
large businesses who by the way are
still operating and making money have
been given these loans while many actual
small businesses have not and this is
why we were talking about before this is
why you cannot shut down the economy and
expect the government to fill in the
gaps the government is not nearly
competent enough for that is far too
corrupt and even if the government was
was perfectly benevolent and competent
it still would not be able to do this
you still won't be able to shut down a
Multi multi trillion dollar economy
grind it to a halt and have a
bureaucracy step in and nothing is lost
lost in translation that it just it
would not work it can't work all right
finally let's go to your daily
cancellation today we have to cancel CNN
anchor brian Stelter who perhaps you
might say has a bit of a melodramatic
streak and so over the weekend he
tweeted this is what he tweeted take a
look he says last night I hit a wall
gutted by the death toll disturbed by
the government shortcomings dismayed by
political rhetoric that bears no
resemblance to reality worried about
friends who are losing jobs kids who are
missing school and senior citizens who
are living in fear I crawled in bed and
cried for our pre-pandemic lives tears
that had been waiting a month to escape
I wanted to share because it feels
freeing to do so now is not a time for
faux invincibility sure knows are living
this hating this like everybody else
okay now listen this is a
time for all of us and I agree but pull
yourself together man pull yourself
together
be a man for God's sakes you can you
imagine I asked the ladies in the
audience I asked you to imagine us what
would you do if you climbed into bed at
night and you found your husband there
sobbing Oh be honest okay you feel bad
for him probably what party you feel bad
for but at the same time
wouldn't you be at least wouldn't at
least part of you also be embarrassed
for him as well unless he has a good
reason obviously and you know we've gone
over before what are the good reasons
what are the acceptable reasons for a
man to cry there are only a few but if
he's crying because his dad just died or
another immediate family member okay oh
because his team just lost in the
playoffs or because the cat jumped up on
the counter and knocked over his bottle
of whiskey that would be acceptable or
because he just watched the movie Rudy
that that would be fine or because he
was just stabbed in the stomach now only
in the stomach he'd establish on the arm
or the leg and I mean it's walk it off
right but if stag stabbed like in the
gut and if it just happened 10 seconds
ago maybe you're the one who stabbed him
then I think you have to allow for a few
tears a few manly tears and then you
know it also allow for for tears related
to fatherly pride so for example if your
son hits his first home run in Little
League you could cry over that also
fatherly shame so if your son if we're
you know five games in the season and
your son has not even gone to hit yet
hasn't even got a base hit he strikes
out every time because he's a bad
athlete then you might weep a little bit
in the stands when you realize that your
nerdy son has no athletic skill
whatsoever so either of those all allow
but but that that's pretty much it and
hopefully if you if you see your husband
crying over that you'll consult him
because that
manly cry but if he's crying because
he's stressed about stuff that's
happening in the world well then yeah
part of you pities him but the other
part of you is worried that you may have
accidentally married a woman
the real problem though is I think just
talking about it publicly like okay you
cry you have a nervous breakdown
whatever you don't need to advertise it
to everybody else as a man you shouldn't
be going around telling people that you
cried last night have some self-respect
even if it's for one of the acceptable
reasons that's still it's an intimate
moment maybe one other person witnessed
you cry I mean as a man there should
only be a very few people in your life
who have ever seen tears exit your tear
ducts and and you don't want to share
with everybody else so have some
self-respect and if you don't have
self-respect as a man then you're
cancelled which will give you another
thing to cry about
I suppose all right and of course we
haven't even I mean we could even put
all that aside in just the fact that
he's again trying to make journalists
the the victims and the heroes of this
it's just repulsive so but that's it we
will we'll leave it there I'm gonna go
have a good cry myself I'm I'm scheduled
for one and I'll talk to you guys
tomorrow
god bless stay safe Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producer is our Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling our technical
producer is Austin Stephens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 hey everybody its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon is turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clifford
[Music]